when he was about to go to sleep the
call came and not like that it was nice
that they called again if i
didn't answer yes verena we want to
take the sprinter tomorrow at six from
berlin to cologne to the ism to the
international confectionery fair part is
up until bushheuer can do that  not because it
and sugar substitute amylose it's
not yet approved in europe and
then we can't meet without a manufacturer
and ask me why it's clear
we've just finished recording
verena poster and lea
kramer have just left and have everything tell us about their new ones
projects about your political
ambitions such as founding iris barth about
your investments about your visits to
the confectionery fair much much more
it was very entertaining he is
interested in all topics that our
leading digital women are currently dealing with he
has now and watch
this video  welcome to this podcast with lea
kramer and verena poster
to mr podcas  t an episode
that i was really looking forward to because
there is so much in it first of all
the long-awaited return of our
regular guests in leer but not alone
but their new podcast companion
and who has also been a regular
guest at the airport corinna
so they both fit together  doubleheader
welcome teacher trainer hello
we are happy at the same time i
also after that i last
saw
hamburg a few months ago
but not that long ago in
hamburg and that shows how crass the times are
easy and that you can  do
n't really know what you can be euphoric about now
because the tool made
dinner with berlin with yes
that's exactly what i had won from the
founder at auctioned off at the time against
then everything to startup teams to the
organizations and evaluate
these dinners together exactly i had to leave beforehand
i was never he us
continue and need where from and wladimir is in
now
Kyiv well and what's easy yes i followed him all the time on instagram you even if you get a little bit there so the fastest news somehow also in english and such and no idea of course i only have contact with him but it's absolute shocking so we also talked about it yesterday what can you we can't even assess that these camps we can't classify them we can't classify them we can't help as it's not our our area and still i think the only question you can ask is I have to ask myself what can I do myself what can I do myself what can I do myself and yesterday, for example, in addition to donating and supporting organizations and posting the optical media and so on, I took my kids and we cleared out all the storage and the brought things and somehow went to rewe and lidl and bought diapers and so on and from  brought
to individual people who are
currently organizing trips to the
ukraine with trucks full of relief supplies,
exactly from berlin, a lot of people are really involved
unbelievable about that is great and
exactly what you say follow the people who are
there right now, so
don't think that we can judge everything from
berlin or wherever why are
, but simply
dock to the people who are now at the
forefront  front are there trucks
driving back and forth there are
three points where you
can bring things and i support one
side in particular the match
basically beds and accommodation for
people in germany with refugees
from the ukraine and that's crazy there
over 100 1000 beds have already
been made available within
six days
and there has  t you have the feeling that this is such
immediate aid that works when the
families or the people arrive with us now
that it is not just a
question of which accommodation they are going to
now the un said they are expecting five
million
refugees that means it is just
crazy  and of course a lot of them come
to germany and so far i have to
say today i think it's great i think
they are so you can see that they are willing
to help unbelievable
[music
] just talked to felix
oldenburg who they with with better
place that organizes this
portal and he says it's the greatest
civil society courage since the
second world war
that's taking place right now so are
political on the topic don't say speak
a few days before the
transporter appears you'll make that even
more difficult but in general
i think we're the wrong ones
You can only help to evaluate that and we'll see
how to do it best and where
to where m  here on site like yes and its
reach to give a voice to
those who may not yet have that much
reach but who are
providing much greater help
yes maybe the transition where we just
now talked about politics is
a thing that I already know  I
thought about it beforehand and wanted to ask you
because I'm probably the only one
who has heard that's normal in Germany in the last few months, even
just before the election
it was right but it was hot right
now i have so
many rumors let's tell you what was what
about it so first of all it's so if you
're in the middle of it yourself then it's
funny you get it yourself from the
bild newspaper that you're being treated as a digital
minister so  it's
not like someone tells you beforehand
that they're considering you or
kind of knows that  that comes tomorrow
but it just comes there you
look around a bit helplessly and I have to do something I
have to report somewhere now but that's just
how this
political Berlin somehow works there, people just
get jobs and then it happens
let's see what's getting so much resonance
so insofar as i think i've
really been traded now no but
i would have been willing to say i
'll be going into digital politics in particular for four years
because i have the
feeling there's still something going on and  on the
other hand i'm non-party and the
country already noticed people
aren't necessarily waiting for someone
who can't even commit themselves to a party to
somehow clean
up germany so i think
i'd really put my hat
in the  also have to throw the ring when it comes to
his party and that has
n't happened to this day because i
always have the feeling you give so much
independence and freedom of speech
at the moment when you do that and in
the end there were three parties in the
government so if we
had had one yes then maybe the
chance would have been that they said we would take
one but if you are here you have
you can distribute them then you can take
them in and take them but now
let's see i was a
big fan of the digital ministry that
's not there now so it's a
bit there but not really and i
wish you the best of luck of course because
I'm only concerned
with seeing them fail now, but I
still don't believe that if you
continue to spread this over so many houses
that something good will come out of it in the end,
but you're not close to a
party at all, but you already have
close to the fdp and the green
i would say i have a lot of
points of intersection with
politicians of the parties but yes how
empty says a first one  I
always have to decide on one and secondly,
if there are three
of them dividing the posts between them, then someone
will be brought in from the outside line, so I would
have found it exciting not at all about
my person, only relationships, but in
general, bring in people from the outside,
that’s fine  other ecosystems are also
good but somehow the politics is
apparently not the right playing field
ok and are you otherwise you both
are currently still politically independent
now from the ukraine issue or also
from still active just that the
knowledge came after the election and for the first time
the next course has been set so
i just made
a little angry or courageous speech about
it in our podcast now we must
n't drop everything in domestic politics
as far as education and digitization is concerned according to the motto we now have
the next crisis and and bad down below
war that is terrible and
at the same time not every
minist  erium in germany are dealing with
it full-time right now and i
think there is a little bit of my appeal
we have been pushing the issues in front of us for years,
especially in the education and
digital sectors now
please make schedules
distribute responsibilities and follow up on what
you do and don’t do  always thinking is
the exogenous shock now
unfortunately we couldn't again so it's still my
turn to push things a bit
to make suggestions
so especially in the education sector is total
you've found your mission now
total the you're not leaving either
so  now i'm thinking i had put
such a page homeschooling corona
dot com on the net that's
no longer the topic of homeschooling you
can now put a kind of education cloud on
the net where you can school as
you please now you all have tablets and
laptops that is  now a portal what you have
on it then you can say i'm
fifth kl  aces bayern technical
lessons and then you
come straight to the software that you can use
, so i’m working with my
non-profit association to ensure that
this topic of digital education is progressing, it’s
ok
for me that i do
n’t get involved publicly politically,
so i’ve done it too  coaches and
others who were now a bit more
involved in the elections
noticed how difficult it is to get help
and
and it's incredibly difficult because
he has to keep his voice and not have to
speak politically but to
say things apolitically, i.e. politically correct
, so to speak, and so simple
staying with myself and that's not
my world so i think i'll continue to do it
on a small scale in private in private
rounds i get involved and
help where i can both things that
are important to me but i don't do it in
any
public stage  but that was
never so i sometimes felt
and the acting perso  nen in berlin
so the minister has become even shorter
so
partly also personally or privately and
is closer to verena hubers now in the federal parliament
who previously sat with us
at dinner with the founders or
johannes vogel real schröder so such a
young politician christian lindner so
many others in  hamburg so many who were
not just looking for proximity during the election campaign in
order to look good but because
they really
wanted to exchange ideas that i
think is a new quality that you
really know a lot of people in politics and
not because of lobbying  view from
kalkar call and dictate something to the error
but short distances meant
meet for lunch say how is it with
you how is it with you can
help somewhere there are topics that we can support from the
outside that there you notice
the generational change for me
otherwise  is it so if you are now being
followed and I am following linkedin
at  instagram and so that you
don't have a classic job now
so it's clear that you'll also be managing
director founder of companies that was
somehow
a while ago in both cases and we've been
talking regularly since a year about
what
he scratches
and how it is  my job
your position so i think i do
n't know myself can be self-employed and
do a wide variety of things i think
the big difference between
me is that verena totally loves this potpourri of
life yes but say so or
and i actually
look for something and you have to  to say that i think
the part that you ca
n't not get in public now
was yes i got me yes or
we split up with two children so
me and my partner split up at the time and
that brought about a big change
in life our life totally
restructured and wanted to
do it incredibly well for the children and
that was what I meant  main project
actually lately and that
was so important to me that i knew
just as close to making a decision and accepting such
a change i can't
found founding is ubiquitous that kind of
eats me up in a positive way
and we did it 1 1 and me
I'm incredibly proud of it and if
it continues like this I'll eventually write a
book about it about healthy breakups
and unhappy love breakups but
that meant that
I just didn't have the
energy for it and my energy and
my priority was somewhere else and now I
have it  we did well and it's going well
and now i'm noticing that the
energy is back and i
'm watching the foodtec very closely, i.e.
all sorts of topics
in the food sector because i just
think i read a book like that by
eckart von hirschhausen and  he said
my mother was born in 1950 when
we were two billion people in the
world and  20 50 are 14 and we
just don't live in an empty world anymore but in
a full world and have to
feed all these people somehow are
fire and then also feed them in such a way
that we don't get all sorts of problems
because we only eat crap and
many just when we do  has children
you can tell that totally and
i dealt with two topics 4 i became a
vegetarian myself that means i
look at all the alternative
protein topics so how can we
finally produce meat without killing animals
and the other is i look at myself
a lot of gamblers topic
because i noticed that somehow
our kids and 50 percent of the kids
travel too much in addition to the fact that
we were less than the six
it was almost a
wednesday evening going to bed the call comes and i
like that too but not that they still
call me if i didn't
answer yes verena we want to take
a sprinter from berlin to cologne tomorrow at six o'clock
ism to the international confectionery fair
until you can't do that because it and
sugar substitutes all lots of it's
not yet approved in europe and
then we can then meet leone manufacturers
and don't ask me why it's clear
[laughter] in the
evening and always ten we have
six children together  to organize that it went
somewhere the next day yes well
we are really we sat at 36 in the
sprinter to cologne so the most crass
energy rhein-main philipp it's
not that easy to come to such a trade fair
because im because i can't
so  this is a video like knives i.e.
i then said with my affiliated
company yes i want
to be close there does not apply because they are
not in the confectionery
sector ok i wrote it i am a musician i
just want something crass toads stay
but that you are no longer enough that
means we had two tickets to lea
sophie kramer and then we
thought at the entrance hey let me in
first  go because if it was with
you then pieper know lea sophie kramer in
contrast to me so I
marched through and was in there quite confidently
and with her it was more like an excuse
that is not possible they are already in and
we are so bright how can I go  be
and stands even then she also
got in so that was the
biggest hurdle ever to come to this completely empty fair
then the
bus came like the interns of
this german
federal association of the german confectionery industry
or something like
that, yes, in which one there was chocolate
because the  hear me want goods so ok
contest
what makes sense well definitely
what do you remember after the film
pappa ante portas has loriot it was then
like evelyn hamann on this praline train
where she somehow tried the 48 praline
her totally green face  is
and you felt that way yes you
are there from stand to stand the people
we tell and it is quite healthy here now there
is no sugar in there  is,
however, a sugar substitute that
drains and while i got it
but it's chilly but the grazer an
idea where he says okay the actual
look i already had but the
problem is with this substance that you
want to work with so that's a part
the organic sugar should
all be eaten loose from the sugar cane the
americans have
been allowed to do this for ten years is not allowed here yet
it should come last year
comes now only 20 24 25 in europe and
that means she can’t do anything
with it now and that’s it  neither
can you certainly found something at some point
with yes because it has a tenth
of
the calories as in real sugar which is
awesome and 70 percent of the sweetening power and the
same quasi consistency and completely
plant based completely organic sugar
only a tenth of the calories so
really a lot  first of all a
huge package from the usa ordered from
smart suite, they'll do it and then the
food  n let's think about
it that means that's how it was that this day of the day
is the take away of the day was
this industry still alive behind the moon
we thought we'd get there and every
second talks about gymnasts of the shooter
and so they don't think about it at all
they are very happy that there is no one there yet
somehow there are already the
changes now a katjes the
complete no exception but just the same
is already and I think also with the
all loose would come and so but
it is still there let me say it is from a
scale  it's so little that they
really are exactly that, yes you think
that should be their main focus
topic and it's one of a hundred
so that will follow that walter
but we still have
a bit of time, so to speak, because you like  I said yes,
you can't do anything yet because
it has to be approved by the EU first. I
thought it was funny, it was around and
then there was pamela reif
's her she  then the chocolate
then to pay attention so that's
exactly
the people weren't there of course the
reasons as funny but
she has the fair was then really
the things are shown department
stores supermarkets or the world's largest up to
now have once a year in
no way  So since the 70s and
what I also noticed but I think
I why I noticed that is
you at least thought about it and
deferred it before the topic of
food came up in the banking area what to
do in
the report is not separate
we would have the money of course
documented as honest as
original lea and how räder founding so
the idea existed committed
quickly discarded exactly that was
last summer when we were something of a party
and it really was such a bank
for women and that doesn’t exist yet
and  it needs it and everything has
to be rethought because why
don't women invest because the previous neo
banks  didn't really offer that either
and so and then we rushed right up to you
and said
we have to film it from the beginning
without knowing what will happen, yes, fast
forward it didn't come out at all, which was
a bit because of that
On the one hand, we suddenly realized
that we wanted to be a banker. Somehow, we
hadn't thought about it beforehand, that
it's a heavily regulated industry
with a lot of negative
connotations, and we were a bit
worried that we were going into the
largest Bafin regulation according to wirecard
that ever existed we are pretty much a
labor party when you look at how
big the neo banks are and this
forecast women need that and are looking for
that they somehow verified themselves a
bit in n equal to 1 conversation
everyone saw who cool
when  there was and at the same time
we weren't sure there weren't any
competitors at any other banks
that really made it great  well managed
to get women to invest
so or shall i say get women
to feel comfortable with
their assets think it's great with their money
and like to invest and be
sure to explain everything uk
is going on the stock exchange right now that's a big one
been a role model but we
thought a bit if that doesn't
exist it could be on the one hand that we're totally
crazy that we've found out now
or that's just
really not necessary or it doesn't
work like that and that's why
we hit the brakes  because
we once looked deep into each other's eyes and
said we're really going in there
with everything we have or
don't traumatize ourselves and that was of
course such a weak moment for
both of us those were weak moments and
at the same time a strong one  I
because somehow we didn't have to prove anything on anyone
that we have to
hold out now, but if it just
doesn't anymore  r makes so much sense or your
hypotheses that you had before are just
not right then almost then
you'd rather say quickly we'll stop now
and put the brakes on than that you
somehow and up until then we had
only invested money ourselves now you
want  of course pretty happy that we
aren't now we're about to be
launched that you have now i'm coming in
this turbulent capital
markets come with me is your
money really cool so now a little bit
i think immediately that we
missed it but of course you're
awesome now  video footage we can think
about what we do with it at some point, honestly, but the
topic has remained the same,
we now have a huge event with
women, so somehow 60 women or
something in berlin, that's not for the press, so to speak,
but only for us because we're
with  who want to talk about how
we invest in startups because we
actually like to get more
women in st  art ups in knows what
exactly she's doing well i heard
tonight well while we also after the
meeting in
berlin founded a circle of friends with blood from
various
projects women's fair
honestly so we've now
said well first of all it would be there in
rehnaer is there  katja
suding invited lena gercke caro dauer
very, very many women from very
different areas did not reach their
destination mercedes also influenza comes
from cologne and two big ones in there
julia bush and everyone probably
understands in the end how close how can we mixed the net
so to speak well actually
we said we would launch our
podcast we would like to celebrate that we
want to celebrate but somehow celebrating that in itself
is stupid let's do an
event where we can somehow say
awesome there is now in the podcast
at the same time above all something to give
back and something  was given back to me I
've had very strong notices lately, including
in my circle of friends  I have a
lot of people I
spoke to about investing, yes, and you
almost always managed to get at least
17 of them and so on and then
invest in funds in
startups and so on and above all
things women too because women
still invest less and this
startup
environment has not been accessible
to people outside of the state so far
and yet they have an interest as
well as a lena gercke or is the
following also known do i go there personally
purely privately or thoroughly ug  and
I'm involved with what actually
the bafa investor christian somehow 20
percent of the investment from the start
okay I first have to know that there is
and where is that 1 then
I go there somehow with what kind of
tickets did the 10,000 euros or
50,000 investors have  is e.g. I'll start
with yes that I say watch out now if you
say you want to invest in
startups  ren also directly as a
business angel and for many also be in
plants that makes sense because they then
also do cooperations at the same time
and do something like that then he thinks about it he has
an amount and thinks about it right away when
you look at it through tough
that he can split into ten different
Most of the startups go in who then say at the beginning
I've found one now,
relatively a lot of money back then, so that does
n't make any sense anymore because you simply
know what the risk profile is like for the startup in
brass and I think it's
very much about the fears
also to create access to connect people with
each other because most of
the companies then don’t even know
about poland because not everyone has
somehow now 50,000 euro tickets,
count them but then say look, get
together, there are
already the first ones  networks need to say
that's
also the basics to explain yes
and so easy to explain that you
don't worry oktobe  r comes but that
you can even do that, I can do that too
. Lena Gehrke will soon be sitting
somewhere with her assignments
the
founders say i don't
feel like buying so many smaller tickets,
i'd rather take fewer larger ones and
that's basically a reflection that there's so much
capital in the market and that it's
about the sales, so
the business angels are fighting each other  this
business angel round ticket in a
dreary discuss what he
even invested now very briefly how many
investments do you have
yourself so 30 30 and you
somehow 30 40 ok so
investment is a topic and
to explain to people that we are on
there was a topic that I noticed from the
second time here,
which I would of course like to address
hen is because we will always be
allowed to be and that's also a bit
of the podcast that came out of the
deceased documentary
so now there is this lounge
celebration there is a podcast of you and
yes you have a kilo fast and furious
everywhere where there is a podcast  are you two
looking for katharina or teacher on the cover and you will find that how
come so why now we had a podcast we
were totally keen on it so i
don't know in december important to certain
why we don't actually always do a
podcast together then we can
over  talk about all these topics then
we would see each other regularly
then we are also forced to ask ourselves again and again
what kind of
knowledge do we still have inside of us what can be shared
we are welcome to invite guests who ask
questions themselves what to learn yes and I think that’s how
the fact that we then
said we're not founding together now that
was so cool too then I can do
another project together where we are  r
know what we can pass on
yes and knowledge increases if you
share it we just both do a lot of
talking a lot of women the mails and so
on and then I can finally
bundle everything and pack it in and
we found that somehow and there is such a thing  what
not so i also told you the numbers
only 15 percent of the women host i.e.
the host of business podcasting
women that is super little so the women
then follow less heard and so on
that means you have to be able to
change that somehow and talk at the same time  we
yes about women
would be better i have my cell phone on it
no and at the same time lea says that from
the beautiful our trailer we
are two women but we just talk
about topics that interest women and men
equally so it is
not a women podcast with
women about  women on women's issues
it's just a podcast of
teaching and me on business issues that we
find exciting from the wii invested
how do you get a work-life balance
we
invited flow heinemann and said
we want to discuss that with the
officer who also has four children or
have with lukas von cramer from run
football publicity as a founder is
actually cool or should it
rather let it be so that's why it's going to be such
a colorful ride through the vegetable garden
and is
published
weekly every thursday stein weekly
and we didn't cancel
full of rides we were of course
happy
proud of the fact that we'll have you there, so to speak,
soon in the portfolio I wo
n't disappoint I am  certainly when
I hear that there is already a launch
party, so to speak, with which we
wouldn't have to say that we just brought it to
life and
you really have opportunities to
tell things that the tensions
want to create with the product and have
about it  spoken I'm very
curious and
only now is the practice e  So
if ours appears here then you can also
say one you can say that
immediately afterwards okay I wish over and
subscribe to fast and kohl's
[applause]
[music]